you guys this week me nothing I was I
wanted to talk about your meltdown last
week I saw a picture on Twitter of your
your penis no what no he took that down
that had something to do with the
meltdown but you know take us through
your meltdown last week what happened
last week you had me I can't name names
but get a big audition I pretty big
audition for a show and I had a fully
memorized I had a fully worked you know
man here I go to Universal and there's
the star the producer is a star big star
big star mm-hmm household name hustle
name and I walk in and I have it all
prepared and all of a sudden this person
says hello to me in the room and she
starts introducing me to people in the
room as if you guys are like friends
yeah and you know each other right or no
hey I do okay but not much I mean I
respect this person mm-hmm I look up to
this person but I'm intimidated by this
person and I had the worst audition you
could ever have in your life to the
point where as I walked out of the room
I literally started war crime and then I
took a bottle of water that I had I
started banging my head you know me I
was so crazy what happened so you had it
all prepared yeah III was there the
night or I was with you up until that
morning we had you know the lines down
what got in the way did you did you did
your excitement of her acknowledging you
cloud your short-term memory yes I don't
know what happened but let me tell you
this right now you will never happen
again
that's I'll tell you why why because I'm
now gonna go out okay that's it
retirement episode I don't know I
probably this pilot season I think done
with that because you know what I think
for right now the little things I'm
doing on love is enough and
[ __ ] that I'm getting sent out for isn't
right and it's like it's like you know
they're just trying to throw me into any
situation because my agents are scared
that like I'm gonna get like complain
like I'm not getting any traction right
but at the same time I'm a fat [ __ ]
cuckoo I think I'm very funny I believe
that you know and people believe that
I'm funny but I'm not gonna be forced
like you know how about you play the
head of the FBI I get auditions like
that and I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm not
gonna get that mm-hmm
you mean you're a strong man in a circus
no one's made you audition yeah a strong
man yeah and they give you a piece of
metal and then I'm like they're I could
pretend to bend it I could yeah even if
I pretend but if I do it no one's gonna
believe that I can do this you know so
it's like you know I the one audition I
had that was actually good was written
kind of for me which was I'm gonna tell
what it is but it was a rule that I go
all right this is like something that is
in the realm of possibility your
wheelhouse yeah but you know I mean
they're just throwing me out there and
it's like [ __ ] it it's like I don't
really need to do a three camera sitcom
right now why don't we just create Bobby
that's great stuff let's create you know
a perfect role for you yeah
we're people with who tell stories on a
podcast absurd stories it is we can
write about a three camera sitcom me you
and Gilbert right but it's the human
centipede is the scientist right and I
want to be the middle because I'm the
front you're the front my mother
tied to your butthole movies already
been made so like what about this
centipede is different it's your baby
okay you're the caboose you're the back
and the reason why I want to be in the
middle is so that I don't have to have
any lines and the only one that talks is
George I mean now Oh Gilbert it's
Gilbert
yeah you have all the lines so you keep
muffling in my but I'll do all I can do
to the moon
right and then if I had to poop I go and
then you go you have to eat it so I
based it on the [ __ ] let's pitch it
to what network is this Fox all of it oh
my god let's go although it's just an
Asian version of this entity because
Human Centipede yeah and it's like you
only talk we just walk around the house
right well maybe they still like sitcom
me scenarios like yeah we get Clint
yeah the laughs a lot we get a live
audience
yeah oh that's fascinating so what do
you think I'm down how do you actually
pitch the show network for yourself oh
yeah I've had deals before and I'm what
my very first pitch I'm gonna tell you
this one this is all so ridiculous so I
went in and I I thought this was a good
idea so I walked into a pitch and I said
okay here it is
I'm a Korean kid but I'm not yeah I
don't have an accent you know man well I
was raised by my grandfather was very
Korean okay and my parents had both died
and they're like okay so it's me and my
grandfather and we will run a hotel
because that's interesting yeah I good
but here's the catch then I pointed to
the sky a hotel in space oh you [ __ ]
lost them as soon as I said that I lost
them but you checked this out
imagine a a sitcom okay right kind of
like Star Trek right but my immigrant
grandfather and I run this [ __ ] like
it's kind of like a you know it's not a
halfway house but it's more like a motel
6 in space like Sky City yeah so there's
like degenerate just face the Jetson oh
yeah yeah and like you know I mean like
my immigrant grandfather arguing with an
alien that does have any eyes this is a
real movie or an animated movie the TV
show it's a live-action pitch the
live-action three cameras had come I
like it
I dig it
[Music]